here's a brief look at imaging with
fluorescing material the wonderful thing
about our photography is that we can
image at very long shutter speeds this
particular image was taken at four
seconds and i was on a tripod so we can
do that when we have the right equipment
you're looking at a series of vials that
contain nanocrystals and I am exciting
it with ultraviolet lamps here is
another image that I'm not crazy about
that's the image that the researchers
would have preferred I then went back
and started playing with the cuvettes
with all these cadmium selenide
nanocrystals I placed it in this order
then I made it a little more random
you're not going to do this all the time
but it happens that this particular
material was screaming to be played with
and it was really important research
about quantum dots in these next two
images here's one that was taken under
UV light because these gels in the petri
dishes are also fluorescing different
wavelengths of course from the previous
one and here it is with fluorescing with
UV light and room light I had a
combination of both on these and here's
another example of those quantum dots
this time they were infused into plastic
here is a purely UV illuminated image
and once again I decided to turn on some
available light and it's a sort of a
combination of using the UV lamp and
available lamp light in the lab